Miley Cyrus talks her 2013 split from
Liam Hemsworth and reveals her
excitement over Kelly Clarkson and
Jennifer Hudson joining the voice
[Music]
[Applause]
next you the 24 year old Malibu singer
was a guest on the hits one in Hollywood
radio show Friday where she opened up
about the advice she'd give herself
after she and Liam called it quits
almost four years ago know that
everything is happening for the right
reason didn't know if that was end of it
or knew if we'd be back together again
but knew that wherever I was going I was
on the right path
everyone's happy smiley also admitted
she's excited to be coaching season 13
of The Voice alongside Jennifer Hudson
and is happy that American Idol alum
Kelly Clarkson would join the show for
season 14 to keep a career like Kelly
Clarkson his hat or Jennifer Hudson you
have to continue to work really as hard
Miley went a step further and revealed
she's bringing on her dad as a mentor in
hopes of taking down reigning champ
Blake Shelton rain up the top a big guy
you're bringing out the sick I'm
bringing in dad
you